let's talk about why men live healthier
and happier lives with younger women
and for that i have a
study here which is right there
and let's throw that up on the screen
share okay i'm gonna try to make this a
little bit bigger i know some of you
guys are on mobiles when you do this
ah screwed up my placement okay here we
go
figure three okay you can go um
the title of this study here i'll read
you the title after i um
after i get to the uh can you guys hear
me oh okay
volume seems a little low i'll turn it
up a little bit for you hopefully that
helps
all right let me just highlight it here
so
in this chart we've got shows the risk
of dying in men increases as the age gap
increases
so the younger the wife is compared to
the spouse
actually i should highlight it from here
the younger the wife is
compared with her spouse the lower the
mortality rate of the husband
the older the wife is compared with her
spouse the higher
the mortality rate of the husband
compared with the reference category an
excess mortality rate of more than 30
percent can be found in married men
who are more than seven years but less
than 17 years younger than their wives
married men who are more than 15 years
less than 17 years old sorry married men
who were
more than 15 years but less than 17
years older have a chance of dying
that's four percent lower
you have a lower chance of dying the
study by the way you can go look it up
it's called how does the age gap
between partners affect survival
so the long story of sorry the too long
didn't read version of it is
younger women will let you live longer
that's just the reality of it all
okay so date younger women
run a harem of young women if you want
if you can there's nothing wrong with
that so i got another one here because
this is
because this is the societal norm here
that uh grinds my gears
uh share screen and let's go with tanya
sweeney
i don't know if you know who tanya
sweeney is but this is tanya
sweeney's article how older men's
fixation with younger women
really boils my kidneys
oh man you gotta love these eh older
men's fixations boil my kidneys
poor tanya i always tell you guys to
consider the source yeah
whenever you read these articles is it
going to click through for me
this is this is good old tanya here and
if we're being honest do we have
there's another one i pulled up here
about a blog she wrote about a
tinder date just so you get frame on who
she is
tanya sweeney on her disastrous tinder
date after giving me the once over he
announced he had a friend to pick up at
the airport right away this is in 2016.
she's just had a kid recently so
obviously you know she found somebody to
lock down and make babies with or a baby
i suppose she's
she's probably towards the end of her
reproductive lifespan
she looks like she's about 40 or so but
um
anyway that's her so in this article
that's grinding her uh kidneys or making
her kidneys burn what was it boiling her
kidneys
i didn't know you could boil kidneys but
anyway so in this article
she's citing she's complaining how
russell crowe is dating
his new girlfriend brittany throat age
and the girlfriend's closer to crow's
son's age than his age
more she calls them dad dad bottled
media middle-aged men uh leonardo
dicaprio 46 and his girlfriend camilla
23 dennis quaid 66
his wife laura 27 and sean penn
with his wife 32 years as junior earlier
this year
then she goes on to complain about brad
pitt brad pitt 56 to be dating a 27 year
old model nicole
blah blah polar tursky
i think that's the um that's the chick
that was actually that is
married to an older fashion designer
from somewhere in europe i talked about
this about a year ago in another cast i
think this is the same check
she's she's actually in an open marriage
and brad smashing her
um and then she goes on to praise keanu
reeves
and his older uh girlfriend who's 47. uh
you guys probably saw the picture of
them together at an event in the last
year because it got it went viral she's
she looks a lot older than him but she's
in fact a little bit younger
and then this is the best part this is
the pot calling the kettle black
okay because towards the end you know
she's complaining all about
her kidneys boiling because men are
dating younger women
she's complaining in another blog about
a tinder date where she got abandoned
uh when the guy showed up and gave her
the once over top to bottom
about four years ago and then she closes
this article
this is grant but i know from experience
that this isn't always the case and
maybe this is why the dynamic leaves a
metallic taste in my mouth
at 20 i get i'm guessing this is tanya's
20 year old at 20
working in a dublin hotel bar to pay my
way through college i met an american
man
then in his mid 30s so this guy's 15
years her senior
he was charmingly boyish but had his own
apartment in la
wore aftershave and worked as a record
producer i could barely spell career
it was a sizable step up from the snake
bite guzzling lads that i was more used
to
suitably smitten i moved to la after
college so we can make a go of things
she picked up and moved all the way to
la from dublin
to chase down this 35 year old chad
because he's not a snakebite guzzling
lad
okay so even though she's complaining
about mandating
younger she admits in her youth when she
still had beauty
i don't know what she looked like
younger but she doesn't look so hot
today as you saw in the other picture
when she still had beauty she dated
older men in fact 15 years
her senior this is the this is like
solipsism 101 guys you know i talked
about
hypergamy and solipsism being the main
driving forces of women
and this is this is them not seeing
pastoral notes she actually titles an
article complaining about
men dating younger women boiling her
kidneys and she closes the article
admitting that this is what she did
herself
you